sometimes shootings can happen because
children gain access to their parents
guns but one Las vegas-based company is
trying to address that Joshua peguero
was at the 45th annual Shot Show held at
the Venetian looking into those efforts
to keep guns out of children hands
my local is looking at me
already Carl casico was a fabricator
building sets for entertainment shows on
the Strip but then the pandemic came
along and he lost clients with the free
time he built this device you don't even
have to look at it so you watch
thank you
it's a gun case that opens only using a
person's fingerprints the case is
designed for a car or house and it
deploys a gun in one second after
detecting the owner's fingerprints it'll
save lives it could save your life your
family's lives you and most people a lot
of people
that leave the gun laying around because
it's fast access even if they have kids
that's stupid Federal data shows that
guns became the leading cause of death
for children in 2020 while the product
is still new casino is already taking
orders from store owners churches and
schools I've actually had schools
interested
and you ended up with all the school
shooting you you could program all the
teachers and staffs fingerprints I can
white color the SHOT show is the largest
trade show of its kind there was some
vendors showing the latest in sport
hunting technology with this technology
we've Incorporated video recording which
is very popular so you could actually
record what the scope sees during your
hunt and you could share it with friends
and family with the hundreds of vendors
attending the SHOT show as you saw with
faststar there's increasing discussion
on how to make gun ownership safer
putting into Venetian Joshua peguero
eight news now
fast armed is currently taking
pre-orders for its biometric gun case
which has yet to hit the market